[موسيقى]
نحييكم واهلا بكم الى التاسعه هذا المساء
وهذه عناوينها
[موسيقى]
واشنطن توافق على استخدام كيف مقاتلات اف
16 ضد القرم وموسكو تردوا باستهداف في
مطار دانيبرو
ت
مع اقتراب دخول الهدنه حيزه تنفيذ الامم
المتحده الالتزامي باتفاق جدا
لرفع سقف الدين بكين ترزخ تحت 20 تريليون
دولار من الديون المحليه
عاصم
بعد اكثر من 16 ساعه من التحليق رائده
الفضاء السعوديان علي وريان يدخلان المحطه
الدوليه
[موسيقى]
وفي تفاصيل التاسعه هذا المساء الضوء
الاخضر الذي منحته واشنطن لاوكرانيا
والاوروبا لتزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات اف 16
واستخدامها في القرن قابله رد روسي سريع
تمثل باستهداف مستودعات اسلحه وذخيره
ومعدات طائرات اوكرانيه في مطار دانيبرو
المتحدث باسم الدفاع الروسيه قال ان
الضربه كانت دقيقه ونجحت في تحقيق الهدف
منها بعد ان تسببت في تدمير عدد من
المرافق بالمطار ومن بينها موقع تقني
لتجهيز الصواريخ المستشار الالماني
وصف تدريب الطيران الاوكرانيين على
مقاتلات اف 16 بانها اشاره الى بوتر
للتراجع عن اهدافي في اوكرانيا وقال في
تصريحاته لصحيفه ديفالتا الالمانيه
لن يحقق هدفه في اوكرانيا من خلال مواصلته
الحرب وجعلها طويله الامد اوضح ان المانيا
لا تملك طائرات اف 16 لتزويد اوكرانيا بها
لذلك لا تناقش تدريب طيران اوكرانيين
حاليا الا انها تقوم بتزويد كييف بالدفاع
الجوي والعربات المدرعه والمدفعيه الثقيله
على حد قوله
اذا المقاتلات اف 16 صقور قد تقلب قواعد
اللعبه في سما اوكرانيا وتقد مضجع روس
فاعطاء الرئيس الامريكي الضوء الاخضر
للحلفاء بتسليم طائرات اف6سين اوكرانيا
وبدء تدريب طيارينا اوكرانيين عليها اعقبه
تحذير روسي من تورط مباشر للنيتو في
الصراع لكن كيف وبماذا يختلف تسليح الغرب
لاوكرانيا بالمقاتلات رغمى عشرات الحزمات
العسكريه قبلها سفير موسكو في واشنطن تضرع
بعدم وجود بنيه تحتيه لتشغيل مقاتلات اف
16 في اوكرانيا مرجحا فرضيه اقلاع
المقاتلات الامريكيه من قواعد الجويه
للنيتو كما لفت الى نقص العدد المطلوب من
الطيارين وافراد الصيانه ما يعني ان
متطوعين اجانب سيسيطرون في الجوف
اذا مقاتلات اف 16 او الصقور المقاتله
تشكل عامله ثقه لمواجهه الروس وهي
المقاتله الاكثر مبيعا واستخداما في
العالم قاتله خفيفه الوزن ذات محرك واحد
تتميز بسرعتها ومرونتها وقدرتها على
المناوره حيث يبلغ طولها 15 مترا وطول
جناحيها عشره امتار تقريبا تصميماتها
تغيرت منذ تصنيعها لاول مره في سبعينيات
القرن الماضي فهي الان متعدده المهام
قتاليه تقصف تكتيكيا قادره على الدفاع
الجوي كذلك يذكر ان السلاح الجوي
الاوكراني يعتمد حتى اللحظه على اعداد
صغيره من طائرات قديمه هذه الطائرات تعود
الى الحقبه السوفيتيه من طائرات ميغ 29
وسخوي 27
واشنطن تقدم الضوء الاخضر لتسليم مقاتلات
اف 16 للجيش الاوكراني بعد تزايد الضغوط
عليها هل ستغير المقاتلات ميزان القوى
المقاتلات ستساهم في تعزيز المجال الجوي
الاوكراني وحمايه البنيه التحتيه وصد
الهجمات الروسيه المكثفه المقاتلات ترصد
اهدافها بدقه في جميع الظروف لها القدره
على استكشاف الطائرات المعاديه
واشنطن رفضت تقديم المقاتلات خوفا من
تسريب التكنولوجيا التي تعمل بها الى
موسكو ديميترو كوليبا وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه هناك حاجه لتطوير السلاح الجو
الاوكراني لصد الغارات الروسيه
افدى حكم بان مجموعه تابعه للجيش
الاوكراني وصفها بالتخريبيه دخلت الاراضي
الروسيه بالمقاطعه وقال حاكم المقاطعه ان
القوات الامنيه بالتعاون مع حرس الحدود
والامن الفيدرالي تتخذ الاجراءات الضروريه
بهدف مواجهه هذه المجموعات من جهه
تسلل مجموعه من المخربين الاوكرانيين
تسللوا الى محاوله لابعاد الانظار عن بخمت
اما عن اوكرانيا فالمخابرات الاوكرانيه
قالت ان مجموعه الروسيه معارضه لبوتين هي
التي اشتبكت مع الامن في
نذهب الان الى موسكو معنا من هناك مراسل
العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد ومن كيف صحفي
محمد بابا اهلا بكم ما معنا في التاسعه
هذا المساء عبد الجواد ابدا معك بلدي كانت
تريد هذه المجموعه التابعه للجيش
الاوكراني التي تسللت داخل الاراضي
الروسيه عبر مقاطعه
مساء الخير
الامن الروسي الان يتحدث عن وضع القومي
كما سمته
ليفكن الاوكراني والذي دخل اليوم الى
مقاطعه بيل جراد كمطلوب للعداله في
الاراضي الروسيه اين موجد او خارج الاراضي
كما يتحدث البيان هذا ما تتحدى ما يتحدث
عنه الامن الروسي طبعا حسب الروايه
الرسميه نادين هذه المجموعه دخلت من ثلاث
مناطق عبر الغابات في مقاطعه بيلغراد هي
مقاطعه ملاصقه للاراضي الاوكرانيه ومتاخمه
للكثير من المناطق الساخنه هنا طبعا ليست
هي المره الاولى التي تتعرض لها هذه
المناطق لدخول جماعه اوكرانيه تقريبيه كما
سمتهم موسكو لكن هي المره الاعنف ادت الى
اصابه ثمانيه مدنيين من من مقاطعه بيلي
جراد دون وقوع طبعا اي ضحايا طبعا اجلاء
كبيره للمواطنين الساكنين في القرى
الحدوديه المنتخبه للشريطه الاوكراني جرت
اليوم طبعا قامت موسكو او قامت الجهاد في
تلك المناطق بالتعتيم على هذا الموضوع
لغايه خروج السكان من تلك المناطق ومن ثم
طبعا تم الاعلان رسميا عن هذا الشيء هذه
اللحظه نادين يعني تتوالى الاخبار
والتقارير من بيل جراد وابرزها يكمن في ان
الاحتفالات بانتهاء العام الدراسي ستجري
عن بعد عبر تقنيه الفيديو ولن يكون هناك
حضور للمدارس وماذا عن الجانب الاوكراني
وتحديدا محمد اليوم اين تتركز الاشتباكات
وتشتعل بعد بخمط طبعا
نعم بالفعل ولكن يعني تعليق عن تحيه لعبد
الجواد تعليق على ما يحصل في بولغو
الاوكرانيه ووزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه اكدت
انه لا علاقه للقوات الاوكرانيه او لاي
مجموعه اوكرانيه بالحادث الذي يحصل او
يستمر الوضع الامني في بيلورت بل يعني
تقول وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه وحتى يعني
ان هذه المجموعه هي مجموعه من الجنود
الروسي الذين يعني خرجوا وانفصلوا عن
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وبعضهم كان
محتجر يعني كاسرى في يعني خلال المعارك
كان محتاج كاسره وتم اطلاق سراحهم من قبل
الاوكرانيه الجانب الاوكرانيه يتنصل بشكل
كامل عن مسؤوليته في هذه الاحداث التي
تحصل وفي منطقه اما بوضع العمليات
العسكريه الجيش الاوكراني وبحسب مصادر
خاصه لنا يعني مؤكده هذه المصادر ان
القوات الاوكرانيه خرجت من داخل مدينه
باخمت وهي الان تتمركز عند مدخل مدينه من
جهه الجنوبيه الغربيه بالقرب من حيليتك
تراجعت انسحبت القوات الاوكرانيه بعد قصف
عنيف من الكويت الروسيه وخاصه يعني كان
القصه يستهدف الابنيه التي كانت تتواجد
فيها القوات الاوكرانيه ايضا في منطقه
القوات الاوكرانيه هجوم كبير للاتصاليين
ويعني القوات القوات الروسيه التي كانت
تحاول اقتحام الدفاعات الاوكرانيه في
منطقه اضافه الى قصف عنيف تتعرض له تلك
المدينه تستمر ايضا عمليه الاجلاء السكان
من محيط مدينه الى المناطق الامنه عبر
وزاره اعاده الدمج ويعني اجلاء اللاجئين
الاوكرانيين التي تعمل بشكل نشط لاجلاء
المدنيين في تلك المنطقه تخوفا من نقل
وحدات الى تلك المحور الذي يعني هناك الان
اشد المناطق اشتباكا هي منطقه
بعد هدوء يعني نسبه الى حد ما في محيط
باخذ القوات الاوكرانيه خرجت وهي تقوم
بعمليه حصار من الجهه الجنوبيه والغربيه
والشماليه لمدينه وفي هذا الوقت عبد
الجواد لماذا تريد موسكو تكثيف هجومها على
مطار دانيبرو بالتحديد حيث كان القصف
والعنوان الرئيسي فيما يتعلق بالتطورات
الميدانيه هذا الصباح
رقم موسكو عبر بيان وزاره الدفاع للحديث
عن ان ضرب هذا المطار العسكري فينيبرو
ياتي كرد على قضيه اف 16 موسكو طبعا تحدثت
اليوم رسميا عبر وزاره خارجيتها وقالت
بانه رغم الدعم الكبير للجيش الاوكراني
موسكو على قناعه بان اف 16 ستصل للقوات
الاوكرانيه لكن اهداف العمليه العسكريه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ستنفذ كما كان مخطط
لها لديها طبعا كل الثقه كما تتحدث بان
اهداف هذه العمليه ستستمر وسيتم استهداف
هذه المسيرات ما يحدث فقط هو تصعيد كبير
للموقف لا يمكن اخفاء قلق موسكو من قضيه
من قضيه المقاتلات والصواريخ بعيده المدى
نادين لكن هو تصعيد للازمه كما يرونه
وسيمود بعمر الصراع في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
حسب ما تتحدث الدفاع والخارجيه عبد الجواد
الرش د من موسكو ومن كيف الصحه في محمد
بابا شكرا جزيلا لكما
[موسيقى]
روسيا لن تجلس مكتوفه اليدين بانتظار
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد المتوقع دفاعات
مكثفه بنتها خلال هذه الاشهر وبينتها صور
للاقمار الصناعيه اربعه مواقع اساسيه دخلت
ضمن خطط روسيا الدفاعيه وتقع جانبيعها
جنوبي اوكرانيا اولها الساحل الغربي لشبه
جزيره القرم والمشهور سابقا بمنتجعاته
الشاطئيه على الساحل المنتدمه مسافه خمسه
وعشرين كيلومترا استبدلت موسكو كراسي
التشميس والمظلات بكتل خرسانيه هرميه
الشكل مصممه لسد مسار الدبابات والمركبات
العسكريه الاخرى خلف هذه الخرسانات خط من
الخنادق والمخابئ يوفروا غطاء من الهجمات
القادمه وسط ترجيحات بان تكون هذه
الدفاعات اجراء احترازيا وليس توقعا لهجوم
الاوكراني بحري لان الاخيره تمتلكه قدره
بحريه محدوده خطه روسيا تشمل مدينه
الصغيره هذه المدينه الواقعه على طريق
رئيسي جنوب شرقي البلاد يمكن استخدامه قبل
كيف لعزل القرم عن الاراضي الاخرى التي
تسيطر عليها موسكو شبكه ايضا من الخنادق
حفرت في خطين شمال وهو الاتجاه الذي يجب
ان تهاجم اوكرانيا منهم وخلفها توجد حلقه
اخرى من التحصينات من ثلاث طبقات من
الدفاعات مع احتمال كبير لتواجد الالغام
بين خطوط الدفاع خط من الخنادق والخنادق
المضاده للدبابات يمتد على مسافه 35 كم من
الطريق السريع الرئيسي اي واحد صفر خمسه
وهو غرب توكماك والذي يربط بمدينه خاركيف
اما رابع المواقع الروسيه والمحصنه فهي في
منطقه الجنوب وتشمل ماريوبل وهو هناك
خنادق مستديره قرب قريه ريفنوبل الصغيره
على بعد حوالي 55 كيلو مترا شمل ماريوبل
اذا كل خندق مستدير به كومه من التراب في
الوسط ربما لحمايه المدفعيه او حتى السماح
للجنود بالاحتماء وتحريك المدفعيه حتى
تمكن من التصويب في اي اتجاه
[موسيقى]
قال وزير خارجيه النمسا
انه لا ينبغي ان تسبق اوكرانيا دولا
اوروبيه اخرى في الانضمام الاتحاد اشيرا
بذلك الى دول البلقان واشار الى ان
اوكرانيا يجب الا تكون اولويه بالنسبه
للاتحاد الاوروبي كما قال ان بلاده تحتفظ
بقنوات اتصال غير رسميه مع موسكو وانا على
الغرب مواصله الحوار مع روسيا مشددا على
اهميه استخدام المنصات الدوليه لتعزيز
الحوار مع روسيا مثل منظمه الامن والتعاون
في اوروبا والامم المتحده مشيرا الى ان
المسؤوليه العالميه تقع على عاتق الدول
الغربيه
[موسيقى]
ساعتان او اقل بقليل تفصلنا عن دخول
الهدنه في السودان حيزه تنفيذ العاصمه
الخرطوم شهدت اليوم مواجهات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع مصادر خاصه للعربيه افادت
بان الجيش السوداني اطلق قذائف مدفعيه
ثقيله باتجاه مناطق تمركز لقوات دعم
السريع بالخرطوم ياتي القصف المدفعي مع
تواصل اعمال العنف والمعارك في انحاء
العاصمه كما سمع دوي انفجارات في مناطق
متفرقه من بينها منطقه الصحافه
نستكمل في اخبار السودان حيث قال قائد
قوات الدعم السريع في السودان محمد حمدانو
ان قوته لن تتراجع عن موقفها الا بانهاء
ما وصفه بانقلاب الجيش السوداني ومحاكمه
كل من اجرم في حق الشعب السوداني والعوده
الى المسار الديمقراطي حيث اتهم في رساله
صوتيه اتهم الجيش بنشر الفوضى وزعزعه
الاستقرار
نؤكد ان تمسك قوات الدعم السريع باستعاده
التحول الديمقراطي وانهاء الحلقه الشريره
التي دمرت السودان
الاندلابين يريدون تكرار تجربه الثلاثين
عام الماضيه نحن نديم قص المدنيين
والمستشفيات والمصانع وباقي البنيه
التحتيه بالطائرات والمدافع الثقيله
ونترحم على الارواح البريئه التي فقدناها
ندعو الشعب السوداني الى الانتباه الى
مخططات الفنون وحملات التضليل التي تهدف
الى توسيع دائره الحرب لن نتراجع الا بناء
هذا الانقلاب ومحاكمه كل من اجل في حق
الشعب السوداني والعوده الى المسار
الديمقراطي
نذهب الى اندرمان ومعنا من هناك صحفي
مقداد حسن مقداد اهلا بك معنا في التاسعه
هذا المساء اليوم هل يمكن القول بان بوادر
هذه الهدنه التي يفترض ان تبدا حيد
التنفيذ وتدخل حيز التنفيذ في الساعات
المقبله بدات تترجم فعلا على الارض
مرحبا نادين مساء الخير على جميع
المشاهدين نعم خلال الساعات الماضيه هنالك
بوادر واضحه جدا في مدينه ام درمان على ان
هذه الهدنه اصبحت محل ترقب ومحله كذلك
مراقبه حتى من السكان المحليين ومن من
جميع اطياف المجتمع الجميع يراقب هذه
الهدنه ربما لانها بمراقبه اول هدنه
بمراقبه دوليه نحن منذ ساعات لم نشهد اي
اشتباكات او تحليقا لطائرات الاستطلاع
والطائرات المقاتله ربما هذا الصباح او
الساعات الاولى من صباح هذا اليوم كانت
شديده وكانت كذلك مصاحبه لها عمليات
استطلاع وطيران جوي وانفجارات متعدده
ومقذوفات انطلقت من سلاح المهندسين وكذلك
القوات قوات الدعم السريع ترد بكثافه لتلك
المشاهد العسكريه
ومناوشات نعم هذه النقطه التي اشرت اليها
فيما يتعلق بانه نوعا ما هناك حاله من
الهدوء تسبق الساعات الدخول الهدنه حيزه
تنفيذ اذا ما قارناها بهدى سابقه اعلنت هل
كانت الساعات الاخيره ولحظات الاخيره
مشابهه للحظات اليوم
نعم يمكن ان نصف ان جميع الهدن السابقه
ولدت ميته ونادرا ما تحترم جميعها كانت
يعني نشاهد اعمده الدخان ونشاهد
الاشتباكات ونشاهد كذلك الطيران الحربي
يحلق وطيران الاستطلاع وتحركات عسكريه من
قوات الدعم السريع والقوات الجيش السوداني
وبالتالي فان المواطنين
بطبيعه ما حصل وما حدث في الايام السابقه
كانوا يعني يترقبون ان ان تكون هذه الهدنه
تدخل حيز التنفيذ بصوره بصوره اكثر يعني
اطمئنانا واكثر تنفيذا على وجه الارض
وبالتالي فان هذه الهدنه وما صاحبها هذه
الهدنه خاصه التي برقابه دوليه يمكن ان
نصف ان ما صاحبها من خلال الساعات الماضيه
يمكن ان تكون اول هدنه تدخل حيز التنفيذ
ونحن نترقب كذلك ما ستسبره ساعات القادمه
وما ستسفره الايام من اي اختراقات يمكن ان
تحدث عسكريا على الارض المواطنون يترقبون
خاصه الذين تاثروا بصوره واضحه من هذه
الحرب طيب مقداد الاستفاده انسانيه
بالدرجه الاولى من هذه الهدن بالتالي هل
من بوادر على الارض لانفراجه قريبه فيما
يتعلق بالوضع الانساني وضع المستشفيات
الطرق الامنه للوصول الى المستشفيات وغيره
حتى لا هذه اللحظه لا بوادر يعني امن
الطرقات ولي كذلك المسارات الانسانيه
الامنه المواطنون يمكن ان نصف ان هنالك
شجاعه منهم حيث ان الذين تضرروا يذهبون
الى اعمالهم باعتبار ان انهم فقدوا جميع
ما يملكون ويحاولون ان يؤمنوا قوت يومهم
وبالتالي فهنالك تحركات توصف بانها شجاعه
من المواطنين لكن لا مسارات امنه حيث ان
الذين يتحركون في مساحات شاسعه من شمال
مدينه درمان الى جنوبها تصاحبهم مخاطر
عاليه جدا في الايام السابقه لكن
المواطنون اضطروا لان يخرجوا من منازلهم
لكي يؤمنوا قوت يومهم ونحن نتحدث عن سته
اسابيع منذ بدايه هذه الحرب الجميع تضرر
وبالتالي فان ما ستسفره هذه الهدنه من
ممرات انسانيه امنه برقابه محليه ورقابه
من المواطنين ورقابه كذلك من المجتمع
الدولي يمكن ان تحسن الوضع الانساني في
شتى مناحي الحياه انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر
على كل هذه الاحاطه من انظروا من الصحفي
مقداد حسن
قال المبعوث الامامي للسودان فولكربرتز
قال في حاطته اثناء جلسه مجلس الامن
الخاصه بالسودان بنيويورك انه لم يمر يوم
منذ الخامس عشر من السودان دون قتال بين
الجيش ودعم السريع
لم يمر يوم بدون قتال بين الجيش والدعم
السريع منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل ونحو 900
شخص قتلوا بينهم اطفال بسبب الاشتباكات في
السودان واكثر من مليون شخص اضحو مشردين
بسبب استمرار العنف والكثير من السودانيين
حوصروا في منازلهم ويفتقرون الى الامدادات
اود ان اشير ايضا الى ان القتال ادى
لاندلاع توترات قبليه واثنيه خاصه في
دارفور طرف النزاع في السودان انتهكال
قانون الانساني الدولي
التاسع هذا المساء مستمره ونتابع في
سياقها ولكن بعد قليل
ناطحات السحاب روائع نيويورك العمرانيه
تهدد باغراقها ومنهاه قد تكون ضحيه الاولى
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في التاسعه هذا المساء
ورطه محليه قد ترهق الاقتصاد الصيني اي
ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في العالم وتتحول الى
فوضى وعبئ طويل المدى فديون المحليه
الصينيه تقارب 23 تريليون دولار من ضمنها
الاقتراض الاف شركات التمويل التي انشكتها
المقاطعات والمدن وفقه وكاله بلومبرج
الامريكيه ورغم ان احتماليه تخلف الصين عن
سداد الديون المحليه المنخفضه نسبيا الى
ان هذه الديون تقلق المستثمرين بشكل
متزايد وقد تضطر الحكومات المحليه الى
اجراء تخفيضات انفاق مؤلمه خبراء
اقتصاديون اكدوا ان الحكومه المركزيه
قادره على ابقاء الامور مستقره على المدى
القصير عبر مطالبه البنوك بتمديد الديون
المدن والمقاطعات المحليه ولكن من دون
تمديد للقروض ستعجز اكثر من ثلثي المحليات
على سداد ديونها في الوقت المحدد ما
يعرضها
فرض عام 2016 ينص على بدء اعاده الهيكله
الماليه اذا اعاده الهيكله تشمل فرض بكين
اجراءات تقشفيه صارمه هذه الاجراءات اذا
اذا ما تحدثنا عنها منها خفض الاجور تاخير
صرف المرتبات تقليل الامتيازات الطبيه
للمواطنين وارتفاع اسعار الكهرباء والغاز
وزياده ايضا الغرامات الماليه بالنسبه لي
الصين
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى بكين ومعنا من هناك اناره تنجين
اكاديمي وباحث في الشؤون الصينيه سيد انار
مرحبا بكم معنا في التاسعه هذا المساء على
العربيه من كان يتخيل ان الصين لديها ازمه
ديون محليه بالتالي هل من انضباط مالي في
الصين اليوم
هناك حمله تضليل معلومات صحيح ان الصين
لديها ديون محليه كما هو الحال بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده وهذه ديون محليه وليست
ديون وطنيه التي تعد منخفضه بالمقارنه مع
الولايات المتحده القصه قد صدرت وبرزت من
خلال
مساله
اخفاض في الولايات المتحده في التعامل مع
ديونها
المحليه المتعلقه بتمويلها الحكومي منذ
عام 2019 هذا يعني بانها تنفق اكثر مما
تحققه من انتاجات وهذه الارقام قد تضاعفت
بواقع كبير الدين الوطني يعني بان
الولايات المتحده تستدين الاموال من اجل
السدادي ما يجب فعله اما بالنسبه للصين
فالقصه مختلفه فالحكومه لديها الكثير من
الادوات التي يمكنها ان تستخدمها
على خلاف ما
يوجد في الولايات المتحده وكافه الاوضاع
الحاليه تحت السيطره في المرحله الحاليه
هذه المخاوف غير صحيحه ولا اساس لها من
الصحه ونحن لن نعمل على تخفيض الاجور او
تقليل المزايا المواطنين كما جاء في معرض
تقريركم وفقا لقانون عام 2016 يعني هذا
ليس تقري العربيه هذا تقرير بلومبرك فقط
للتوضيح سيد انار اذا ما تحدثنا عن اقتصاد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واقتصاد الصين
اقتصادا مترابطان ويؤثر كل منهما على
الاخر وحتى على العالم بالنسبه للتداعيات
الاقتصاديه كيف يمكن قراءه المشهد بعد ذلك
يعني نتحدث عن ازمه سقف الديون فيما يتعلق
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حوالي 32
تريليون دولار وفيما يتعلق اليوم بالصين
يعني نتحدث عن 23 تريليون دولار
المتحده
تبلغ مدينتها واحد وثلاثين
مليار دولار وليست ترليون دولار وتذكروا
ان عدد سكان الصين يبلغ اربعه اضعاف ثم هو
موجود في الولايات المتحده
لكن الاجور لا اعتقد اننا سوف سوف نسعى
الى تخفيض الاجور هذا لن يعني اي شيء
بالنسبه لعمليات التمويل وهذا هل الدين
المشكله عالميا نعم ومنتشر كنطاق وهذا ما
حدا بالبنوك اللي رفع اسعار الفوائد في
الامر الذي جعل من مساله ديون مكلفه
للغايه وخاصه بالنسبه للدول الناميه هناك
حاله من الاخفاق لدى مجموعه دول السبعه
ومجموعه الدول العشرين في التصدي لهذه
المشكله وهناك ضغوط كبيره على الصين
للتعاطي مع ما يحدث من الدول الغربيه فيما
يتعلق
بتقديم اكافه
الميزات التي تخفف من الاعباء الماليه
وهذا ما رفع الى ادى الى رفع سقف الديون
بصوره كبيره بحيث يتم فقط تخفيض هذه
الديون من قبل اقرار من الكونغرس وفي
الصين
ووفقا لما جاء في تقرير بلومبرد
للاسف لا توجد لدي التقارير والبيانات
التي وردت حول هذه التخفيضات التي تتحدثون
عنها ولا اعلم من اين جاءوا بهذه
المعلومات يعني وحتى المعلومات فيما يتعلق
بالدين يعني في الولايات المتحده نتحدث عن
تريليون يعني وانت صححت لي قلت بالدولار
ونعود واؤكد بان هاتريليون على كل حال سيد
انار اليوم نحن في العالم العربي هل يمكن
ان نتاثر من هذه الورطه التي تسمى اليوم
في الصين خصوصا انه نمو الطلب على النفط
كله ياتي من الصين
طلب الصين على النفط يرتبط بصوره مباشره
بمنشات انتاج النفط وعمليات الخفض التي
طرات الطلب ياتي بصوره اساسيه من الدول
الناميه وبات متراجعا وينخفض بصوره واضحه
من الصين والشرق الاوسط وحجم التجاره كذلك
ايضا مع روسيا مع الدول في اسيا الوسطى
اسيا وافريقيا وامريكا اللاتينيه كان في
حاله صعود الصين تقوم بمزاوله اعمالها
التجاريه ولا تزال تحظى من ميزه تنافسيه
حتى في حاله الكساد فهناك حاجه مستمره
لاساسيات التدفق لنضمن استمرارها وبعض
الدول في ان تقوم بانتاجها بانتاج النفط
وهناك بعض العناصر التي تتم ايضا تصنيع
تصنيعها في الصين فمثلا
الولايات المتحده تسعه لزعزعت الاستقرار
ليس فقط في اوروبا بل في العالم
وهذا سوف يدفع الى عرقله القواعد الماليه
التي تم رسمها من اجل العالم شكرا جزيلا
لك
شكرا لك
وقعوا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتوني
بلينكن مع رئيس وزراء غينيا الجديده جيمس
ماراب اتفاقيه التعاون دفاعي
هدف امريكي جديد في مرمى الصين اتفاق امني
بين باب وغينيا الجديده واشنطن قد يكبل
النفوذ الصينيه في المحيط الهادئ هذا
الاتفاق يتيح للقوات الامريكيه الوصول الى
موانئ ومطارات
البعيده عن الصين بسته الاف
وسبعه وخمسين كيلو مترا المسافه ليست
قريبه لكن الدوله تعد في قلب المجال
الحيوي للتنين الاسيوي في المحيط الهادئ
شراكه امريكيه جديده تاتي امتدادا لوثيقه
شراكه سابقه مع دول جزر الهادئ وقادتها
البالغه عددهم 14
واشنطن اكدت التزامها تقديم حوافز
دبلوماسيه وماليه مقابل الدعم الاستراتيجي
ومواجهه التحديات المتزايده في منطقه
الهادئ وهي تشكل اهميه جيوسياسيه بالنسبه
للامن القومي لواشنطن بحسب الخبراء
بكين كانت قد استفادت في السابق من فراغ
امريكي في المنطقه لكن الطبيعه لا تحتمل
الفراغ ولا التوازنات الدوليه على ما يبدو
الصين سيطرت على المناجم والموانئ بموجب
اتفاقيه امنيه غامضه مع جزر سليمان في
ابريل الماضي نفس الاتفاقيه تسمح للصين
بنشر قواتها في البلاد مما عزز هواجس
شركاء واشنطن في المنطقه لا سيما استراليا
ونيوزيلندا تجاذبات في مشهد الصراع
الامريكي الصيني وسط توقعات باستداد
التنافس على النفوذ في المنطقه لكن فعاليه
الشراكه الامريكيه مع دول محيط الهادئ
تبقى مرهونه باداره التباين بين اولويات
الطرفين فاولويه دول الهادئ تنمويه
واقتصاديه
واولويات واشنطن امنيه
[موسيقى]
تغييرات جذريه عصفت بمجلس الامن القومي
تمثلت باستبدال رئيسه علي شمخاني الرئيس
لراني ابراهيم رئيسي عين علي اكبر احمد
يان رئيسا للمجلس خلفا لشمخاني الذي شغل
المنصب لعشر سنوات احمد يان امين المجلس
الجديد تولى رئاسه المركز الاستراتيجي
الحرس الثوري منذ عام 2006 ويعد احد
الاعضاء الفاعلين في مجمع تشخيص مصلحه
النظام بالاضافه الى تسلمه مناصب قياديه
عده في الحرس قرار تعيين احمد يان يعقب
تاكيد مرشد ايراني ضروره التحاليل
بالمرونه في السياسه الخارجيه كلما لزم
الامر لتجاوز اي عقبات يذكر ان تعيين احمد
ياتي بعد تواتر انباء عن استقاله شامخاني
الذي انتقد كثيرا مؤخرا جراء قضيه علي
اكبر احد المقربين منه هو المدام بالتجسس
لصالح بريطانيا بالاضافه لتراسه مجلس
الامن القومي منذ عام 2013 شغل شمخاني
ايضا منصب وزير الدفاع في عهد محمد خاتمي
ولعب دورا كبيرا في الاتفاق مع السعوديه
بواسطه صينيه
علي اكبر احمد يان الامين العام الجديد
للمجلس الاعلى للامن القومي الايراني كان
قائدا للقوات البحريه للحرس الثوري
الايراني من عام
1997 الى عام 2000 تراس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه للحرس الثوري الايراني بين عامي
2006 تراس المركز الاستراتيجيه للحرس
الثوري الايراني منذ عام 2006 ويعد عضوا
بارزا في مجمع تشخيص مصلحه النظام
[موسيقى]
الوقت يداهم مرشح المعارضه كمال كليتشار
اوغلو اقل من اسبوع يفصلوا عن جوله
الاعاده والضلوع بلحظه نصر ماموله على
اردوغان هذا الاسبوع في عدو فرصته الاخيره
لكسب مزيد من الاصوات والقيام ببعض
التغييرات في استراتيجيه حمله الانتخابيه
الاستراتيجيه تغيرت بالفعل والمعارضه لجات
للورقه الاخيره اي القوميه التركيه راميه
خلفها وعود الربيع والعوده الهادئه
للديمقراطيه واظن سياسته الجديده لتوسيع
نطاق المنتخبين لصالحه ومن ضمنهم انصار
سنان اوغان سيركز كلتشتار اوغلو على وعوده
بطرد ملايين المهاجرين اذا فاز
بالانتخابات ورقه القوميه يلعبها السياسون
الاتراك بالعاده عند حاجتهم لرؤيه نتائج
سريعه لكنها تنطوي على مخاطر ومجازفات كما
تقول صحيفه
اذا تعد انحرافا كبيرا نحو اليمين واشاره
الى الياس الذي بلغه مرشح المعارضه وفق
نائبا سابق في حزب الشعب الجمهوري لفت الى
حاجه كلتشتار اوغلو الى تقديم صوره لقائد
هادئ وقادر وثابت لضمان تصويت الكثير من
الناس كما يخاطر كلتشتار اوغلو بصد
الناخبين الاكراد اليساريين الذين دعموه
باغلبيه ساحقه وازعاج مؤيدين ليبراليين في
المدن الكبرى مثل اسطنبول وانقره اذا
خطوات كيليتش المتعثره يقابلها خصم واثق
ثقه بقاعده جماهيريه كبيره اثبتت قوتها في
الجوله الاولى سته ايام على المتنافسين
على الرئاسه تركيا لاقناع الناخبين الذين
لم يمنحوا اي منهما اصواتا كافيه لحسم
الدوره الاولى في الرابع عشر من مايو
اردوغان الذي قيل انه تعب من عشرين عاما
في السلطه يدخل الى الجوله الثانيه بتقدم
يبلغ مليونين ونصف المليون صوت على مرشح
المعارضه كمال كليتشار اوغلو يواصل تنقله
بين التي ضربها زلزال السادس من فبراير
والتي صوتت باعداد كبيره له في الجوله
الاولى ناثرا وعوده باعاده الاعمار السريع
في هذه المناطق كما يحمل في جعبته ثلاثه
ملايين صوت اضافي هي الاصوات التي صبت
لصالح المرشح الثالث سنان اوغن وهو من
اليمين القومي المتشدد باوغان الذي كان
متريسا حتى اللحظه اعلن انه سيجير اصواتنا
خبيه لاردوغان ما قد يضمن فوز الرئيس
المنتهي ولايته بفارق كبير هذه المره غير
ان خبراء السياسيين اكدوا عدم حاجه
اردوغان لاصوات اوغان بالضروره مبدئينا
استغراب وهم للعب اليمين القومي دوره صانع
الملوك هذه المره واطلاعه بالدور المعهود
للاكراد
[موسيقى]
قرار اوغان بدعم اردوغان لم يحظى بدعم
تحالف الاجداد فرئيس حزب الظفر وميث اوزاك
قال ان قرار سنان اوغان شخصيا ولا يمثل
التحالف واضاف ان التحالف تخلى عن اتخاذ
القرارات والتحرك بشكل مشترك
[موسيقى]
بعد اكثر من سته عشره ساعه من التحليق في
الفضاء وصل رائده الفضاء السعوديان علي
القرني والريان برناوي وصلاه الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه بعد ان اكتملت مناوره
الالتحام للمركبه دراغون مع المحطه
المركبه دراغون كانت انطلقت بعد منتصف ليل
امس من مركز كندي الفضائي في فلوريدا
بمهمه فضائيه يشارك بها ايضا رائده فضاء
اخران هما
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وفي فيديو
بتاتوس سبيس اكس تحدث كل من رائدي الفضاء
السعوديين ريان برناوي وعلي القرنيل المره
الاولى منذ انطلاق رحلتها المتجهه لمحطه
الفضاء الدوليه علمتني المركبه دراغن
تحيه طيبه من الفضاء الخارجي الحمد لله
فضل الله وصلنا لهذه المرحله نحن الان
يعني نعيش حلم ما كنا نتخيل ان هو ممكن
يصير حقيقه الحمد لله
بدعم من الحكومه بدعم القيادتنا بدعم من
اسرنا بدعم من الجميع هذه الرحله ما
تمثلني انا لوحدي ولا تمثل بس طموحي
بالعكس هي تمثل كل الوطن العربي يتمثل كل
السعوديين الحمد لله انه احنا جاتنا هذه
الفرصه ان احنا فقط نبدا نوصل الان لمحطه
الفضاء الدوليه لكن بعد كده عندنا اكيد
طموحات اكثر واكبر من
هالمريخ لازم نستكشف الفضاء هذه هي فرصتنا
زي ما تشوفوا دحين
جنسيات كثيره متجمعه في مكان واحد في
الفضاء هو اللي يجمع كل هذه الجنسيات
مختلفه بافكارهم
واستكشافاتهم ومعلوماتهم
وهذا رائد الفضاء السعوديه علي القرني قال
في اول كلمه له بعد دخول الى محطه الفضاء
الدوليه قال ان تجربه التي سيعيشها
تاريخيه
الحمد لله بتيسير وفضله وصلنا الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه شكرا
لحكامنا
بقيادتهم
وحكمتهم ونظرتهم في المستقبل وتطور
البشريه شكرا لاهتمامهم بمجال الفضاء شكرا
لاسرتي على الدعم اللامحدود اللي حضيته
منهم شكرا لزوجتي واهلي جميعا شكرا لهيئه
السعوديه للفضاء
بتحقيق هذا الحلم للناس وقريبا ان شاء
الله سينظمون لنا الكثير باذن الله شكرا
شكرا عكسيم وسبيسكس على هذه الفرصه كانت
تجربه تجربه الاقلاع تجربه تاريخيه تجربه
سوف تخلد في ذاكرتي الى الابد
اذا بعد ان استهل راائدال فضاء رحلتهما
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه عبر عدد من
السعوديين عن مدى اعجابهم وفخرهم بهذه
المهمه نتابع
اليوم احنا قادرين الحمد لله نوصل فضاء
بشهاب وشاب سعوديين مسلمين عرب قادرين
ينقلون رؤيتنا ويرفعون اسمنا في هل العالم
كله والله شيء عظيم جدا شعور بالفخر شعور
باعتزاز وطني
يوصل للمكان هذه وباذن الله منها لاشياء
افضل وافضل هذه مجرد بدايه بس
بصفه امراه ومواطنه سعوديه اشعر بفخر
وسعاده بالغين اليوم انه حدث تاريخي وكلنا
متحمسون حقا لتوجه رائدى الفضاء لمحطه
الفضاء الدوليه لاول مره
[موسيقى]
لا تزاله مناطق متفرقه من السعوديه تشهد
حدوث حالات مناخيه نادره منها تساقط
الثلوج واستمرار الامطار الغزيره والتي
كان من اخرها ما شهدته محافظه خميس مشيط
الواقعه جنوب غرب البلاد قبل نحو ثلاثه
ايام من تساقط كثيف لحبات البلد نتابع
بعضا مما تم توثيقه عبر عدسات كاميرا سكان
هذه الاحياء
[موسيقى]
مستمره ونتابع في سياقها ولكن بعد قليل
الزومبي ظاهره تجتاح المدن الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
مستمرون معكم في التاسعه هذا المساء وفيها
كشفت محكمه امريكيه تجسس مكتب الاستخبارات
الفيدرالي الامريكيه على مواطنين امريكيين
ودخوله الى بيانات سريه لاكثر من 300 مره
باقل من عام حسب الوثائق يحضر القانون
الامريكي التجسس مكتب اف بي اي على
المواطنين ولا يسمح له بالاطلاع على
المعلومات التي استحوذتها
فضيحه تطال مكتبه تحقيقات الفيدراليه
الامريكي الاف بي اي وقد يكون من الصعب
ايجاد اي تبرير لها تقرير مفصل صدر عن
محكمه امريكيه كشف ان الاف بي اي تتجسس
على الامريكيين عبر الدخول الى قاعده
بيانات شخصيه سريه للغايه وهو ما يحضره
القانون الامريكي
وبحسب التقرير الذي هز الراي العام
الامريكي استخدم الاف بي اي بيانات سريه
300 الف مره تقريبا بين عامي 2020
و2021 فقط
الاف بي اي سحب معلومات شخصيه وقاعده
اتصالات مشاركين في احتجاجات العام 2020
ضد مقتل الامريكي من اصل افريقي جورج
فلويد
بالاضافه الى مقتحم مبنى الكابيتول من
انصار دونالد ترامب في يناير 2021
[موسيقى]
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي استغل الماده
702 اي القانون الذي يتيح لوكاله الامن
القومي دون غيرها الدخول الى حسابات شخصيه
لغير الامريكيين لاهداف استخباراتيه
الماده 702 لا تعطي الاف بي اي مبررا
للتجسس على الامريكيين وفي كل الاحوال هي
تبطل نهايه هذا العام ان لم يجدد الكونجرس
الامريكي العمل بها
غرقوا المدن سيناريو متكرر ضحاياه كثر في
قارات مختلفه كل ذلك بفعل الاقتضاض
السكاني والمباني الشاهقه والتغيرات
المناخيه مدينه نيويورك الامريكيه او
التفاحه الكبيره كما توصف هي مهدده بالغرق
اما المتسبب في الكارثه المحتمله فناطحات
السحاب التي تميزها فالوزن التراكمي
للمدينه يصل ثقله الى واحد فاصله 68
ترليون رطل ويغرقها بنحو مليمتر الى
مليمترين سنويا وفق دراسه للمجله العلميه
ارث فيوتشر اي ان وزن هياكل المدينه التي
تشمل مبنى
كرايسلر يعادل وزن 140 مليون فيل باحثون
ابتكروا نماذج جغرافيه لقياس معدل غرق
نيويورك عن طريق عرض الضغط الهبوطي
للمباني الثقيله على الصخر والطين والرمل
وحتى الطمي اسفل بعض المنطقه هذه القياسات
اظهرت ان منهات الافلام هي غابه خرسانيه
حقيقيه ومعرضه لخطر الغرق اكثر من مناطق
نيويورك الاخرى لاسيما ان جزءا كبيرا منها
يقع الارتفاع متر الى مترين فوق مستوى سطح
البحر الحالي في حين تشهد اجزاء من
مقاطعتي بروكلين وكوينز ايضا معدلات هبوط
اعلى من اجزاء اخرى من نيويورك اذا انخفاض
مليمتر او مليمترين سنويا قد لا يبدو
كثيرا ولا ينذر بخطر قريب لكن الباحثين
حذروا من زياده خطر الفيضانات خصوصا مع
ارتفاع مستويات سطح البحر فالمياه المحيطه
بنيويورك سجلت ارتفاعا قدره 22 سم منذ عام
1950 التربه اذا الاكثر ليونه وفق
الباحثين تزيد ضغط المباني ما يستوجب خططا
لحمايه المدينه وسكانها البالغ عددهم نحو
ثمانيه ملايين و400,000 شخص فالتعرض
المتكرر لمياه البحر قد يؤدي الى تاكل
الفولاذ وايضا زعزعه استقرار المباني
ودفعه للاسفل اكثر فاكثر اخرها كان يسار
ايضا قبل عامين
[موسيقى]
كيف سيغير الذكاء الاصطناعي العالم في 20
30 هل سيقضي على الجنس البشري الحقيقه ان
البعض يؤيد هذه النظريه فما التقدم
المتسارع لذكاء الصناعي تنتشر توقعاته
متعدده عن الدور الذي ستلعبه هذه
التكنولوجيا في حياه البشر والشكل الذي
سيكون عليه العالم في السنوات المقبله ومن
ميزات هذه التكنولوجيا انها ستكون قادره
على الاعتناء بكبار السن او صنع الافلام
والتدريس ويليام هوي كاتب سلسله الخيال
سايلو توقع ان يصبح ذكاء للصناعي قادرا
على انتاج افلام كامله في غضون يوم واحد
لكن على المقلب الاخر يمكن ان يقضي حتى
على الجنس البشري بحلول عام 2030 هكذا
يقول تحقيق لصحيفه ديلي ميل بريطانيه ومن
بين هؤلاء المتشائمين عالم الكمبيوتر
الامريكي اللي عازر يوت كوفسكي الذي راهن
على ان الجنس البشري سيقضى عليه تماما
بحلول الاول من ي
[موسيقى]
حمم على جمالها ورهبتها حلت رمادا داكن
السواد وخطيرا على سكان مدينه كاتانيا
بركانو اتنا الايطالي عاود الثوران مجددا
ليسقط الرماد البركاني على كتانيا وبلده
واحده على الاقل على منحدرات جبل اتنا
الماهوله فيما اعلن مطار كاتاني عن تعليق
عمليات الطيران مؤقتا
[موسيقى]
في نهايه التاسع هذا المساء لم يبقى الا
نذكر بالعناوين
واشنطن توافق على استخدام كيف مقاتلات اف
16 ضد القرم وموسكو ترد باستهداف مطار
داني
مع اقتراب دخول الهدنه حيز التنفيذ الامم
المتحده تدعو جنرال السودان للتزام باتفاق
جده
تكاف
ح
من الديون المحليه
انتهت ولكن اخبرنا بالتاكيد مستمره بعد
قليل 360 ساعه اخباريه مختلفه مع راويه
لنعرف ماذا في جعبتكم اليوم هذا المساء
النور سنتحدث عن المعارك في باخمه وحقيقه
من يسيطر عليها وايضا الملف السوداني حاضر
وملفات اخرى
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات